der österreichische formel 1 rennfahrer
niki lauda ist tot
er sei am montag im kreis seiner familie
eingeschlafen teilten seine angehörigen
am dienstag mit sein unermüdlicher
tatendrang seine gradlinigkeit und
seinen mut bleiben vorbild und maßstab
für uns alle heißt es in der mitteilung
seine erfolge im rennsport sind vielen
noch in erinnerung der formel-1-pilot
gewann dreimal die weltmeisterschaft
zweimal mit ferrari und einmal mit
mclaren 1976 erlebt bei einem unfall auf
dem nürburgring schwere verletzungen
trotzdem kehrte er nach kurzer zeit
wieder auf die rennstrecke zurück die
rote kappe mit der er die verbrennungen
seitdem bedeckt wurde sein markenzeichen
genau wie sein kampfgeist
ich möchte eines sagen ich habe viele
menschen gewinnen und verlieren sehen
diese auszeichnung möchte ich den
verlierern widmen wenn ich kann ihnen
aus meiner eigenen erfahrung sagen dass
gewinnen das eine ist aber beim
verlieren habe ich immer mehr für die
zukunft gelernt
legendär ist auch seine rivalität mit
dem britischen fahrer james hunt die
2013 oder dem titel rush verfilmt wurde
1985 beendete lauda seine karriere als
rennfahrer und widmete sich ganz seiner
fluggesellschaft lauda air die flügel
rund um die welt an bord außerdem
arbeitet er als rennsport experte und
teamchef für rennställe
im vergangenen jahr musste lauda sich
wegen einer schweren grippe einer lungen
transplantation unterziehen
im januar wurde erneut wegen einer
grippe ins krankenhaus eingeliefert er
wurde 70 jahre alt